today on drew we wrap up our look back
at season one our first kiss and
it was not on screen i remember that
it all starts monday the drew barrymore
show is on location from la
hollywood's biggest stars and big
hometown surprises
oh my god we have to stop it all starts
now
[Music]
please welcome drew barrymore
hi everyone i can't believe that season
two of the drew barrymore show starts
this monday september 13th and we're so
excited that we decided to make it a
two-week premiere event celebrating
hometowns and that feeling that there is
no place like home
and next week we're kicking off the
season in my hometown of los angeles and
then we're headed back here to my new
hometown of new york but we want to
celebrate your hometown as well
so write into the drewberrymore show.com
and tell us why your hometown is special
to you
today we're wrapping up a week-long
celebration of our favorite moments from
season one and we have a very special
surprise for an incredible drew gooder
her name is alicia white and she was
born and raised in queens and after
seeing the neglect of parks and outdoor
spaces in her area she created project
pedals a non-profit focused on
revitalization and development of
underserved communities alicia is
backstage right now with her sister
tiffany and guess what they think
they're here to get a tour of the studio
they have no idea we're filming right
now and at the end of the show we're
gonna surprise them
guess what with well you're gonna have
to find out
right now let's dive into more memorable
moments from last season
first up is a guest i was honored to
share scenes with
oh hugh grant otherwise known as hubert
is someone i just love so much and he
stopped in and we covered everything
from our first conversation to our first
kiss and it was not on screen uh-huh
watch this
let's start on
how we first met
um do you remember
[Laughter]
we actually didn't meet in person
um
i uh i reached out to you oh my god you
did you were so nice
you were so nice yes
it was during the dark days of my divine
brown scandal i was just an idiot
[Laughter]
i was a grown up idiot who got caught by
the police and i was back in england
with 5 000
members of the press
uh around the borders of my farm
and i opened a letter from you yes that
was very supportive and nice
and uh it was very cheering up and i
thought i loved drew barrymore words of
support from
an actress i didn't know in hollywood
was lovely so
i've always always have a place in my
heart
i loved you so much that whole incident
just i related in my own life and i
think that
whether it's an actor or a politician or
anything in between
we expect people
to be
infallible
perfect uh never flawed and god forbid
we do anything in our personal lives
that we would like to remain personal
but we don't have that privilege at a
certain point because the cat gets let
out of the bag and
i just uh had to reach out to you i just
appreciated you and i was so i mean and
you were just the most charming human
i
i loved getting to know you on our movie
music and lyrics and it's just one of my
very favorite movies and it makes me
so happy it was a good movie it was a
happy movie it was a i agree with you
i i cause i love to hate the films i've
been in and i do hate some of them but
music and lyrics it's impossible to hate
we're so good in it and so charming if
you think i'm good in it that means a
lot to me because i have the deepest
respect for you beyond your charm and
you know your heart your talent i mean
it's just unparalleled and you've had a
long body of work so you shan't argue me
out of that hypothesis
but it wasn't true i think that film
works maybe maybe we acted quite well
but here's the weird thing we had
chemistry and there were people i
remember before we shot that from it
it's a bit disgusting because he's 180
and she's like 20.
but actually
it
we had a bit of chemistry
we really did and it was funny too
because when you and i met you know you
you can be a bit of a curmudgeon from
time to time
um
and uh and i of course am like a
labrador and heat and like
i'm so excited with joy and so when we
both met we were like oh we're kind of
different people like
okay
that is absolutely true it
and then we really got to know each
other and accept each other for who we
were and it became easy and then we just
used to sit around and laugh that being
said one of the moments that i had some
of the most moxie um and i don't think
we've ever talked about this i walked
into i think it was like the waverly inn
and
this was years ago and i'd had a few
drinks
yes
and i walked in and i ran into you and
instead of saying hello i grabbed you by
the collar and i fully started kissing
you
yes
i remember that
can i do your can i do you of what i saw
yes yes please
i don't think that's true but if you
were like oh that like the expression
was you've never greeted me that way
before
and then and then you like had a second
thought and you were like you know i'm
not hating this
and then um
and then we flirted and then it was like
we were like okay yeah bye see you soon
it was really bizarre
i was very drunk as well and i was with
some
very nice but not drunk studio
executives from l.a
they were very surprised someone said oh
there's drew barrymore i get up to say
hi
and then we make out for 10 minutes and
then i say no again you go and talk
about the script well i guess we've
grown up a bit do you think growing up
is overrated hubert
uh
yeah i hate responsibility i i don't
want this
i'm looking after five children and uh
elderly father
and i don't like it i i keep looking
around for someone more grown up to come
and do it for me
and yet the last time we talked
the way that you talk about the way you
look at life now
having five children's eyes to look
through look after
and look into
you seem
you know like
i'm simultaneously
utterly exhausted and miserable and
clearly the happiest i've ever been i i
i see that now it's so nice all those
cliches are true all that love is just
so nice i think that
not just the children but the wife as
well i have a top wife
you are you must meet her she's
terrifying
uh
swedish
much more manly than me in terms of
it
but
really cool and now you see i'm happy
oh
i just oh you're the best
more memories with hubert when we return
don't go anywhere
[Music]
i want juice dirt i want to pull back
the curtain on some of your most iconic
roles renee was a genius at being
british bridget but i do remember that
she came in for the first read-through
and she sounded
very very
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back all week long we're
bringing you some of our favorite
standout moments from season one
with some director's cut commentary
sprinkled in and when hugh grant came on
the show he revealed some director's cut
commentary of his own we asked him to
pull back the curtain on some of his
most famous films in something we call
behind the scenes and he did not hold
back take a look
i want to pull back the curtain on some
of your most iconic roles in something
we like to call behind the scenes
um okay i want juice dirt fly on the
wall anything that comes to mind
when i mention these movies if you will
please and thank you let's start with
notting hill
there's so much um oh give it to me
hubert
remember the scene with the brownies
we're always sitting around having
dinner and it's about who's going to eat
the last brownie
well i remember hugh bonneville who
americans think is a classy actor
what he got up to during that scene
deliberately putting brownies on my
chair so that i would sit on them in my
white trousers
they could all laugh at my bum between
takes oh my god you remember that um
okay four weddings and a funeral
well i yeah panic i remember the
director he really because we had no
money we made that film for i a
minuscule amount of money and in 36 days
and he just lost his all the time he
would throw his cup of tea against the
walls
i can't make this film
and
and which you have to you've got to
shoot another whole scene here it's two
pages and and he'd say oh but there's
five minutes left in the day and so he'd
say stand against that wall it was like
and we just stand there in a line
and we just see the lines with one
camera on us and that is there is a
scene in the film like that
it took seven minutes to shoot
okay i'm so glad i asked okay
about a boy
not a boy
ah
he's a big star now not that baby but
the the boy
nicholas holt by the way and he's hot
yes yes and we chose him for because he
was such a sort of nerd and
i know he i mean with all due respect he
he is he's posed as a real outsider boy
and he grew up to be really hot
yes yes he did okay
um
bridgette jones diary
well there you have renee
who was a genius uh
being british
bridget
but i do remember that she went through
some interesting phases on the way to
getting that that british accent during
rehearsals
um she came in for the first read
through and she sounded
like princess margaret
dave very posh and
and then uh the next time she came in
someone had told her obviously maybe
bring it down a bit
uh but then she sounded a bit like she'd
had a stroke
[Laughter]
and then she absolutely nailed it i mean
it's one of it's absolute triumph and
and of course she did that accent uh not
just in the performance but between
takes and she never reverted to her
american until the wrath party when that
was the first time i'd ever heard her
speak
with her texan accent and
i quite honestly found it unconvincing
i love that detail and i love hearing
that intel of her process great thank
you so much okay mickey blue eyes
oh well that's jimmy khan
and uh
what can i tell you about well i can
tell you that with my then girlfriend
elizabeth hurley
produced a film
and we had a lot of
let's call them specialists or advisors
on the set who
knew all about the new york mob
let's just say that and
she was brilliant with them if we needed
anything done
she would flirt with one of these guys
and she'd say she's going to sit on one
of their knees and
compare their manicures oh no you've got
such lovely jewelry and such lovely
nails and they'd do anything for us you
know if we had a problem with planes
going overhead ruining the soundtrack
one of them would get on the phone and
suddenly jfk had redirected all the
planes from that particular part of
manhattan
my god i love that story i'll never
forget you and her stepping out and
choosing that versace safety pin dress
you know there are like iconic moments
in fashion and that will always be won
that evening you two stepped out uh well
yeah it ended up that way but i it was
that was pure fluke we were uh
you know unsuccessful actors or not we
weren't that unsuccessful but we were
not
well known in any way and suddenly this
big premiere comes along for this film
and
she has nothing to wear and i think i i
said i think you can borrow stuff i
think that's what
people do they you know the big
designers will lend you something
and so we rang around we didn't have an
assistant or a publicist or anything
like that we
plucked up our courage rang around and
they all said no who are you and then
versace said yes
we got something but only one thing and
they sent it round and it was this is
the one dress that arrived
and she put it on and i i remember
being slightly startled by it
oh i bet you were hot
um anyway and then with the rest is
history it became a thing
elizabeth hurley safety pin dress yeah
that's always going to be iconic all
right our season two pre-party is just
getting started and we will be right
back with more season one memorable
moments in a minute don't move
[Music]
the internet moves so fast they can
barely keep up luckily our team comes
through it every day bringing us jewels
like this
that was a real gem
thanks internet
[Music]
welcome back we're checking out some of
our favorite moments from season one to
get geared up for our big season two
premiere this monday september 13th next
up is a segment where i got to eat
dessert while chatting with adorable
kids it doesn't get much better than
that joshua isaiah caleb and micah are
better known as the yummy brothers
their kid entrepreneurs who turned their
family cookie recipes into a business
and we had a surprise for them and it
turned out they had one for us too and
anyway watch this
how did you guys get into the cookie
business first we went to go ask her mom
when she approve of the business
then she told us to go sit down with our
dad
and our dad eventually he agreed to do
it and we came up with the name and the
logo and it went off from there
joshua what has it been like working
with your brothers and starting a
business
well it's been really fun to be able to
work with my brothers my mom and my dad
and another thing that i really love is
that we're inspiring kids and adults
across the world to be entrepreneurs
i mean
that's so wise micah you guys are going
to school and running a successful
business how are you managing it all
well
how we're doing this is we do our
schoolwork first and then we make the
cookies
caleb what are you going to do with the
money you're making
well actually we created another
business called cantoneur expo which is
an online platform that allows kids
newers
that advertise and market in their
business
uh
that's really smart i learned early that
marketing and advertising is very
important because it's how
you tell your story and it's a great way
for you to take control but also make
sure it's exactly the way you see it
isaiah you are all such cool dudes what
would you tell someone
who thought baking was a girl thing
well drew that's an awesome question
let's say in my trip of imagination
you're on a saturday morning having some
coffee probably just relaxing and you
have your cookies baking in the oven at
350 degrees then when they get out you
take a bite and ooey gooey chocolate all
over your mouth
well yeah
andrew yeah one of our biggest
supporters was our grandfather and he
would always tell us
whatever you put your mind to you can
always do it i am so excited to be
talking to you guys and i know that you
sent us some of your yummy cookies okay
what do we have walk me through it
gentlemen all right
so we have the too faced which is double
dark chocolate mixed with chocolate chip
then we have
chocolate chip
snickerdoodle
then there's cookies and cream
papaya's white chocolate macadamia nut
that was named after our grandfather
because he loved macadamia nuts
and then oatmeal
that we picked out for you is you
juice e.t cookie which is means
extra tasty
[Applause]
gentlemen are so handsome and so
talented
oh my gosh
and the drip cookie there's pecans
toffee and chocolate chip
i i must tell you guys um
these are truly some of the best cookies
i've ever had in my life and i'm not
just saying that
these are perfect their texture is
exactly what you dream of and there are
so many different flavors from all the
different nuts
they're incredible you guys have made an
extraordinary product and i know that
one of your goals is to sell your
cookies
nationwide and i actually
um heard that you would love to sell in
a store and i reached out um to the
owners of slim and huskies the first
black owned pizza franchise in the
country
we go there all the time
their successful pizza empire has stores
nationwide
and i would love to welcome in the
wonderful co-owners of slim and huskies
clint ej and derek
[Applause]
it's great to meet you guys we wanted to
hop on and say congratulations on all
you guys success you guys are true
leaders for your communities and your
families i just want to tell you to keep
on going
the best is yet to come for you guys
man we just want you guys to know if you
focus uh continue doing what you love
with the people that you love man you
can't go wrong so
much much success to you guys
what we're going to do is allow you guys
to sell your cookies in our atlanta
stores how does that sound
great let's go
awesome awesome so what we'll do we'll
work together on a marketing strategy
and we'll figure out how to make it all
work it sound good
yeah great
thank you for having me
we're gonna obviously if we could be so
lucky to have each and every one of you
up on our website at the
drewberrymoreshow.com shining lights on
your businesses we love all of you and
everything that you're doing in your
business communities as well as being
really smart businessmen
thank you so much
but drew
you know what would be good if we did an
exclusive slim and husky special cookie
we liked it we loved it
how impressive are those boys the best
and since we last saw them the yummy
brothers marked a special milestone they
welcomed another brother into the family
business baby andrew is now the fifth
yummy brother and we hear he's been
assigned to the very important task of
taste testing the cookies we wish them
all the very best now we have to take a
quick break so i'm gonna go see if we
have any leftover cookies in our kitchen
so we'll be right back with more season
one memories and fun facts
welcome back to our season two pre-party
and we're checking out some of our
favorite season one moments and i'm
throwing in a little behind-the-scenes
commentary stuff you wouldn't have seen
before i am truly obsessed with this
next guest
all season long i was vision boarding
and trying to manifest that she would
come on the show and finally
my dream actually came true and her
appearance truly sparked joy
this is our conversation with the
declutter queen
marie kondo
take a look
i have a question marie when i first
discovered marie condo i was basically a
hoarder i
had 15 layers to everything
the chair had a pillow and a throw
blanket
and
i wonder when you do
start to take away
and go layer by layer
and get to a more
sane place a less crazy place something
that feels more settled and calm
what do you do when life and kids and
the natural layers of things come back
in
it's really easy to accumulate a lot of
items and and clutter but in those
instances i work with the children to
talk to them hey what's spark story what
makes you happy and i have them
play with and then you you integrate
them into the process
oh
oh yeah no i wasn't doing that
so now i should go with my children and
take them through their things and
figure out what sparks joy for them and
then we can
you know
prioritize what we should keep and what
we should let go of is that the right
advice
absolutely talk about this with your
kids and it's very important that at a
young age they understand what it means
to spark joy and what sparks joy to them
you have a new online tidying course
will you please tell us about that so we
can all watch it and learn
more
absolutely so what this is is a visual
guide to the tagging process and of
course if you read the book some people
can visualize it but this really helps
because it is a very visual medium to
see the process how it gets done and
help people go through the entire
process of tidying up
last week i was mesmerized by how you
fold underwear the underwear you chose
um were uh very petite and i tend to
wear something that
looks more like a parachute
like if there's a fire we should all
grab my underwear and
like use it um how would you fold um
like a fitted sheet or my underwear
so you want to take the most important
bits and fold it to the top like so
inward
[Music]
because this is cotton and it's a very
rigid fabric you don't have to fold it
as many times okay
perfect
i appreciate you so much what you've put
into the world you've helped and allowed
and normalized us asking
what joy is and how we find it
i i think i'm going to have to pinch
myself i just want to say marie that i
i
i
truly
hope
to make you proud i
i i have your picture on my desk
and i hope that i haven't scared you
away
i am ecstatic right now let's go spread
more joy around the world yes
marie i love you you have changed my
life i look at everything now just in a
different way because of you
and we'll be right back with more
memories from season one
[Music]
welcome back we're watching some
memorable season one moments and sharing
behind the scene tidbits some stuff you
didn't see on screen it's a little
season two pre-party of all the amazing
guests we welcome during season one this
big tall and handsome guy
was one of my very favorites
i like to think
we really are birds of a feather and he
even came dressed in the show's
signature yellow color
it's the one
the only my lifelong love big bird he
joined us to celebrate world kindness
day
watch this
how is your morning so far always early
bird
well my day is going great here on
sesame street and and you know the old
saying the early bird gets the bird seed
yes it does yes it does i'm tongue-tied
because i'm so excited to meet you i
have left i'm excited to meet you it's a
dream come true and
today is world kindness day
do you mind explaining what it's all
about
oh sure well i can tell you what
kindness is about
you know kindness is about
it's about showing people
how much you care
and and and you can be kind to to
animals and
and the environment too and and it makes
my friends feel good
when i'm kind to them so so that that
kind of makes me feel good you know
yes it's true i it's um
it's funny the nicer you are to people
strangely the better you feel yourself
but how do you show kindness to your
friends on sesame street well whenever
whenever i'm sad
my best friend snuffy
iggy calls me and he cheers me up and
that's really kind and also grover he
always holds the door when he sees
someone leaving hooper's store with a
lot of groceries so that's really kind
and uh and abby kadabby she's kind to
the earth by watering the plants in her
garden and and that's really kind and
you know what drew even oscar the grouch
can be kind
he takes really good care of his pet
worm slimy
well in honor of world kindness day we
wanted to do a little sketch we're
calling kind tweets get it tweet
tweet know what drew i'm really great at
tweeting
yeah
yeah i tweet all the time tweet tweet
tweet tweet i would love to follow you
on twitter
well we're gonna read the kindest tweets
that we found on the internet to spread
a little happiness today big bird are
you ready oh sure i'm ready drew okay
i'm gonna go first um at dad of five
tweeted hashtag hero when nine-year-old
rhys lost her home in california's
biggest wildfire she also lost her
baseball cards 100 of them and she was
heartbroken and when kevin ashford a
lifelong collector found out he knew
what he had to do he gave her all 25 000
of his own cards
wow
wow
oh i love this okay big big bird tweet
tweet your neck
okay here we go this this one is from my
friend ernie
and it says
for world kindness day
my old buddy burt gave me his favorite
argyle socks to make some new sock
puppets
g-bert that was really kind of you it
says
he's right okay that was so kind okay
one more tweet tweet at the good news
network
tweet seven-year-old boy who was bullied
opens a huge food pantry making his life
all about positive energy i love this
kavanaugh bell told his mom he wanted to
start a gofundme page to fulfill his
mission of assembling and distributing
care packages filled with food and
toiletries for his elderly neighbors and
guess what kavanaugh is here
now
hello hi
hello kavanagh
what an amazingly kind person you are
what motivates your kindness and
positive attitude
well i know we're all going through some
hard times right now and i just want to
make sure that
people know
that people feel happy and that they're
loved so every day i think of
how i can make this world a better place
whether it's by
my care packs or speaking up and
speaking out against bullying i want to
show the world that
being positive is
cool yeah
oh kavanagh i just i love what you said
there it's so so special
how does it feel
to help out so many of your neighbors
it makes me feel so beautiful inside
that
i get to
make have people have what they need
and
my goal is to help a thousand people in
my community but i've helped over 10 000
people not in just my community but all
over the country
wow
and kavanagh how have the people
responded to your
amazing work
well they're usually kind of surprised
and sometimes they cry happy tears
because no one has helped them
like i have
but the most awesome part is i've been
able to inspire kids of their community
like charlie my friend he's in new
jersey he's helping his community and
nicholas my other friend
he is in atlanta or you could say
georgia helping his community
we are all so impressed with you
kavanagh and our friends at sprouts and
the sprouts healthy communities
foundation heard about what you're doing
and would like to help you continue to
spread kindness by giving you 10 000
in healthy food
thank you so much wait look kavanagh
here we go
[Applause]
such a wonderful market with such
incredible produce and healthy food and
beautiful quality
um
companies that they sell oh i just love
them so much and i was so thrilled that
they stepped up to the plate in the way
that they did all inspired by you thank
you kavanagh
thank you so much
i was truly star struck by big bird i
mean who wouldn't be
we'll be right back
[Music]
welcome back it's time to surprise
alicia and her sister tiffany throughout
the hour they've been getting a tour of
our building and are about to enter the
studio and we have to be quiet because
they have no idea that we're filming
oh wow oh hi hi
oh
hi oh hi alicia
my god
oh my god
and guess what you're on camera too
it's so nice nice to meet you
oh my gosh
i'm so excited to meet both of you oh my
gosh i just love what you're doing in
the world by the way i'm obsessed with
your logo too i'm a nut for graphics oh
my god i made it herself y'all made it
myself yes i made the logo myself and
we're obsessed with you like everything
flower
your love for the environment and
everything so our favorite movie yes
ever after yeah so we are so
obsessed well and sisters is my entire
universe now because i have two
daughters so it rules every move i make
and i loved reading about how is it true
you walked off a subway and like saw
this space and
something a light went off yes i was
traveling like with my sister we were
coming back home and so there was like
this environmental space in our
neighborhood where weeds were up to
everyone's ways and there was like trash
and people were using it as a dumping
ground and so i decided that i wanted to
do something about it and improve that
environmental space so that the
community could use it for like
access to transportation gardening and
so that started my organization
and i mean i really want to learn from
you because i feel like um you know
sometimes we look at things that we
would like to change but you actually
went ahead figured it out changed it and
then continued the work on and on and on
so
i mean i feel like we have a lot to
learn from you
thank you so much um i mean the only
thing i could say is like everything
starts with one small step sometimes we
don't think that one small action will
have a ripple effect but doing one small
thing like helping a neighbor helping
clean up environmental space can help
improve communities and help improve our
commun environment so just one small
thing at a time i guess so you did that
and then you kept going and you've done
more spaces right so i do spaces
throughout new york city in every
borough and i connect with other
community leaders or people who are like
hey i have an environmental project i
need help so i give them tools resources
help them with everything that i wish
that i had help with starting out and
now that field that you walked out of
that subway that day and had the light
bulb go off what is it like now so now
like it's a commuter path there so like
it connects all the neighborhoods with
access to the train so it's no longer
dirt path it's no longer weeds to the
hip and people could get to garden and
go out and enjoy the space young people
get to play there so it's a beautiful
space now
i'm so impressed with you
i mean oh my gosh are you guys close you
look so much alike i totally get your
doctors we're very close when we live
together
like we're obsessed with you as well
because like we bought our first home
but we renovated the whole thing
ourselves yeah
everything yeah so we do like
environments with spaces but we also
like yes she's a one-man show like i'm
just like
on project days i help out yeah
not only do i help my daughters have the
relationship that you guys have one day
but since you love being together i'm
hoping that you don't mind if i take you
both to los angeles for our premiere
show
yes
yes
[Applause]
yes
it's jennifer aniston
i know i freak out over her so hard
i love her so much yes we love friends i
love friends we love jennifer innocent i
love friends i love all of her movies i
just love her i'm so excited because
she's someone like i'm never not gonna
want to hang on every word
um so
uh i have these suitcases for you
um that our producer alex clark uh
thoughtfully chose in our signature
yellow we love you you can throw all
your stuff in it and we're flying you to
la and you're going to be there in the
audience and the premiere show as our
special guest oh my goodness thank you
[Applause]
thank you so much i actually um want to
take that kind tennis ball you just
tossed over into our court and throw it
right back onto yours we think that you
guys are amazing and this is going to be
so much fun
all right l.a here we go
and then you can keep teaching me how to
look at things that we want to shift and
change and get on top of actually doing
it and not just dreaming about it yeah i
think that's important and i'm i'm
excited to teach you i mean i could
learn so much from you so like that
means so much to me so yes i'd be more
than happy to all right
let's do this
[Applause]
all right alicia and tiffany i'm gonna
see you guys this monday september 13th
for our season two premiere on the
historic paramount lot in wonderful
hollywood we're gonna have a great
weekend see you soon thank you so much
this is so crazy
wow
thank you
[Music]